(woman)
In conclusion...
the evidence clearly
points to guilt.
The prosecution rests.
(TV sitcom theme music playing)
Whoo!
(music stops)
That was already fun,
wasn't it? Right?
Did everybody feel
happy just now?
You remember?
I know I did.
We've heard an awful lot
from the prosecution
over the last few weeks,
about stuff that may
or may not have happened.
(scoffs)
All these women.
Same story.
Same facts.
(chuckles)
Repetitive.
And how'd that feel
to listen to?
Bleh, right?
But how do you feel
when I play this?
("Dr. Huxtable")
Theo, did you get
your ear pierced?
("Theo")
Uh, nope.
So, I guess
you're just doing an
amazing impression
of Swiss cheese?
(laughter)
Did anyone feel
raped by that?
How 'bout drugged?
No?
Me neither.
I felt comforted by a
familiar father figure.
Nostalgia.
Happiness.
Laughter. Not guilty!
Let's break this
down logically.
I am a good person.
I like this good show.
Like, last time I checked,
good plus good
did not equal guilty.
Objection, what did
she even check?
I just checked!
Defense is talking about
a TV show she likes.
I'm talking about a
beloved show that we love.
Overruled.
I mean, I'm basically talking
about Dr. Huxtable, right?
We are not!
I said "basically."
Overruled.
(scoffs)
Seems like we're gonna
be here a while
with all these
objections.
Would anybody like...
a pudding pop?
(jurors gasp)
Oh, wow.
Would you look at that?
It's unanimous.
How could the face of
such a yummy treat
even do anything bad?
I mean, how would
that even work?
Objection!
Overruled.
(sighs)
Delicious treat, right?
Cold though.
Look under
your seats.
What a fun snack.
What a fun sweater.
Ladies and gentlemen,
at this point,
Bill Cosby probably can't
get in any legal trouble.
That's not what
this is about.
This is about us
not punishing ourselves
for loving great comedy.
This is a court of
public opinion, right?
Let's remind ourselves
what's at stake here.
If convicted, the next time
you put on a rerun
of "The Cosby Show,"
you may wince a little.
You might feel
a little pang.
And none of us
deserve that.
We don't deserve
to feel that pang.
We deserve to dance like
no one's watching.
And watch like
no one's raping.
The defense rests.
(judge)
All right, I think,
um, before we adjourn--
Uh, excuse me, I got
a delivery for the jury.
Oh!
It's from a B. Cosby.
You can put it right here.
Nobody minds.
Oh, my God.
It's chocolate cake.
Huh, do we all feel like
going a little nuts right now?
I know I do.
(singing)
♪ Cos is great
give us chocolate cake, oh! ♪
(jurors sing along)
♪ Cos is great ♪
♪ We want chocolate cake ♪
♪ Cos is great
give us some chocolate cake ♪
♪ Cos is great... ♪
Mrs. Schumer, Cosby
wanted to thank you
for defending him.
(juror continue singing)
♪ Give us chocolate cake ♪
♪ Cos is great
give us chocolate cake ♪♪